stop but to tell you at a wonderful
place but this is a wonderful place on
private property please do not sneak out
there the owners put a ton of security
measures you're just gonna end up
spending the night in jail
respect the owners privacy now join me
on this wonderful video journey which
will show you the place without getting
you arrested in Surrey England
underneath the placid waters of an
artificial lake lay the remains of a
decaying underwater ballroom their past
is both extravagant and tragic about a
mile and a quarter into the woods you'll
find a low stone wall follow that
continue to a small stone building with
the arched doorway go down the spiral
staircase and go through the underground
hallway bathed in the yellow light
coming in through the water above you
you're standing in the underwater baller
Whittaker right wore a lot of hats in
his lifetime when he finally settled on
something settled something big big and
still illegal breaks London globe
company floated bonds to prospective
mining companies and at first his
dealings weren't necessarily illegal
although maybe a little shady
and misleading the line between criminal
and shady was crossed when right floated
a huge loan to the Waterloo Railway this
was outside of his comfort zone and
things immediately went south so he
started writing himself loans and then
other loans to cover those loans
fantástico loan fill that loan built on
loan structure it was like his own
little Victorian Lehman Brothers
collapsed terribly and in 1900 he fled
to America after being dragged back from
New York
to England to stand trial Wright was
sentenced to seven years after the trial
who dagger walked out and asked for a
glass of whiskey and a cigar he took a
drink of the whiskey
he took a puff of the cigar and he fell
over dead what they hadn't noticed is
him swallowing a cyanide pill right
there in the courtroom but what he left
behind was impressive he built an
enormous 32-room mansion on the LIA
estate but the crown jewel and one of
the last things he built in this estate
was this incredibly beautiful underwater
ballroom technically it might not be a
ballroom it was probably sort of a
smoking chamber you know hangout zone
for him and his finance buddies the only
clue to his existence was a statue of
Neptune that poked out of the lake above
it Whittaker Wright was not a man to do
things in half-measures he lived big he
built extravagantly he stole enormous Li
and then he died in the same manner as
he lived with the kind of Victorian
exclamation point today not much remains
of his estate in 1952 the entire estate
for down in a horrible fire but the
underwater ballroom was safe for now
bathed in yellow light coming in through
the water algae coating its windows this
is the leftovers of the extravagant life
of Whitaker red subscribe here and watch
more videos here